has some strong language there from the
president while the Republicans
certainly could color parts of tonight
as a success I don't know if tremendous
is the proper word to describe it there
it was a long shot for Democrats to take
back the Senate although of course hope
springs eternal when you're in the
minority and of course Republicans ended
up actually making gains in the Senate
securing an even larger majority than
they had before as well as sweeping a
few very hotly contested gubernatorial
races that Trump went to campaigned for
in the last days and weeks leading up to
the election so certainly some things to
celebrate on the Republican side tonight
on the Democrat side you know it wasn't
a tsunami but it was definitely a wave
of sorts as we said the the Democrats
have swept not only a majority into the
House of Representatives but have
actually taken even more seats than they
thought they would have latest estimates
I saw were that they may gain as many as
35 seats over the 23 that they needed to
get a majority and there were several
other pieces of good news districts that
were flipped that had been staunchly
Republican a few governor's races that
were won by Democrats previously held by
Republicans some things to point to on
both sides tonight that they can say we
had a good night okay there's a lot to
break down when we look at the popular
vote Maya and that means the actual
number or percentage of votes the
picture is extremely positive for the
Democrats can you explain that for us
how's that possible well one thing that
we saw was very high early voting
turnout in numbers and I believe that
these numbers actually even broke some
early voting records in many states this
is always a tricky number to try to read
into because people who vote early tend
to be people who were going to vote
anyway and those people by and large
tend to be Democratic voters in general
in u.s. elections
more voter turnout equals more Democrats
getting elected to Congress which is
something we sort of saw here tonight
but one thing that we have to remember
is that a lot of these districts in a
lot of these elections are gerrymandered
which means that they are drawn and
divided up in ways that are meant to
sort of give an advantage to one party
or another and there are a lot of races
that we can look into where there were
very very close races in heavily
gerrymandered districts so even though
turnout was high in these districts it
was still favored for one party or
another and ultimately that party ended
up pulling through Republicans it's
about restoring the Constitution's
checks and balances to the Trump
administration
it's about only wealthy special interest
free reign over Washington but more than
anything it's about what a new
Democratic majority will mean in the
lives of hardworking Americans dammit
that's what it's about
Democrats pledge of Congress that works
for the people will have accountability
and we will strive for bipartisanship
with fairness on all sides we will have
a responsibility to find our common
ground where we can stand our ground
where we can't but we must try we saw an
assault that was unprecedented
we saw a hundred-million-dollar race
with Hollywood coming in against the
state with the national media coming in
against the state but all the money in
the world was no match for the good
people of Texas and the hard-working men
and women across our state
[Applause]